The joe rogan experience. Yeah, most
try to come up with the name of it.
They're all the same, but all access
embedded 24 seven a bed. It's very good.
I should, I should remember
the name. It's very good.
They're all the other on this.
This new one is really good cause it's
got Max Holloway running on a treadmill,
two treadmills over from Norma Madoff
who's also running on a treadmill and
they're fucking very cool to each other.
It's very interesting.
It could be thanked him for taking the
time, which she should. She should.
Thanks for taking the fight. And then
they have the same a weight coach like,
yeah, that's crazy. Lockhart, right?
It's Leah [inaudible] card is d.
This is Lockhart working with number
of men on this as well. Both of them.
So Lockhart was like,
Lockhart is legit.
Like he goes over calculations
of like how much you weigh,
how much water you're going to take,
and he's weighing things out.
It took them an hour and a half to do the
calculations. Yeah. It wasn't like, hey,
we're going to wing this. It's like,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're going to do this
weight cut correctly. And
he's got it down to the day,
you know, like it's six days to lose. He
think he was one 71 is that, is that the,
I was wondering what he, what
did he start at? Does it when?
71 so I think he's got to lose 16 pounds.
What's crazy is when Max was on my show,
I was talking to him a little bit off it,
and this is on record, on that spilled.
Anything that he didn't say, but he just
goes, you know, I've, with the injury,
Jesus credit embedded, I think it's
better than that. UFC, not UFC,
the HBO ones.
I think it's been 24 seven how dare you,
I think it's better than only four seven
when there's a big fight generals or
blah, I think, well, I think in general
they're better because they do more of it.
But a 24 seven they're good.
They're fucking good. Very
good. Liev Schreiber. Oh,
I'd love that Bro. Watch her
work. But I like these better.
I only cat Liev Schreiber. Yeah.
Was like till night air wing girl,
but it was nowhere does it say? Yeah,
it was horrible this because there's,
there's almost no narration, right?
Yeah. It's almost just, it tells a story.
I want to see the footage.
How would it like the video of when
they called Max with the fight?
Cause from what I heard, he goes, it
could be that stuff's getting the world.
Fuck yeah, let's go. What? Just saying
why don't they have a video of that?
But no one knew. I don't think they
knew, you know, to to turn the video on.
I don't think Max knew
what they were calling him.
Amazing video of him being like,
it's actually few wins.
This is my thing with Max is I think
Khabib is the toughest fight in the world
on six days notice I'd rather fight
anybody else in the world and could be one
six days because of this style injures
his tenacity. But with Max win,
lose or draw,
whatever happens Saturday night,
if you don't respect and like him
even more after this, you're a moron.
You're a champions on a run,
like Max Holloway's on that would be
willing to take this fight on six days
notice. And also I should say coming
off of a broken foot. Correct.
So he had to pull out of a fight with
a broken foot with Frankie Edgar.
What's just happened?
So I mean how he'll dizzy
and like it said on my show,
he was saying you're not,
I've been doing some Jujitsu,
been the swing of things for me it's
good because I haven't been balls deep in
training. I've just been a little Jujitsu,
you know, getting a light workout.
But it gives me time with my
family and he gives, which he goes,
you know this in camp, you're present but
you're not, which is true. And he goes,
you know, so I'm going through it.
I'm, I'm with my son in the family,
but I'm thinking about something else.
So this has been good for me to really
focus on my family. That was what,
two weeks ago? Three weeks ago.
Wow. So then pay him, you're fine.
Could be even the reason why he wants
to fight Khabib is cause he thinks could
be the best pound for
pound fighter in the world.
And which is nuts because you know,
when you look at it could be Dresner.
It's good. It's, it's, it's,
it doesn't blow your hair back.
He's 25 and Oh for God sakes it's good.
But it's not like all this crazy,
you know, big names on his regular.
But you talked, I was just in San Jose.
John Fitch goes, dude, uh, and this is
John Fitch. Yeah. You know, it could be,
you know, welterweight goat. He's fucking
not cope. He's got damn good. He goes,
I've never seen anyone my
lifetime like could be. He goes,
I fought GSP in his prime. He would
beat him. That's how good he is.
DC said he's the pound for pound.
Greatest fighters ever seen DC
said that he had fights with them.
Like dcs was the heavyweight Strikeforce
champion. He said, he goes, dude,
we go to war. We go to war war.
Like imagine that DC's a Gar,
Willa, he's jacked. I mean,
DC's got some body fat on him.
He's strong as a fucking ox.
You see soak at downtown.
So fun to watch. When DC throws
Josh Barnett through the air,
when they fought Strikeforce,
he just go,
Jesus handled fight was offensive.
That goddamn American,
it was offensive.
He ragdolled Hendo and couldn't be a
cooler guy like the nicest guy ever.
DC might be the nicest
fighter of all time.
One of my favorite people here and Max,
they're up there.
I love him for Isis fighters.
I don't know Max as well as I would know.
Do you see,
because I've done so many shows with them,
but for DC as good as he is to
say that him and Khabib go to war.
I'm like, that's crazy to Josh
Thompson is the cap ne Kay said,
you know Ed Ruth, the Penn state
three time national champion freak,
just start doing MMA and Beltre
complete freak wrestling. He,
I was in San Jose and he, yeah,
I did a show with him and I go,
what were you doing? He goes,
I just came from practice.
Could be second class practice and
go, what was he doing? He goes, oh,
just straight wrestling. I said, uh, who
was the restaurant? He was Ed Ruth. I,
oh my God, the Penn state like legend.
He goes, yeah man, how's that go down?
And he's like, and only one of them's
gone down and it could be like,
what Ruth? And he goes,
oh, he goes, bro it,
I've never seen anything like it.
So there's just this legend of five.
They skipped. When they tell me
that, it scares me like, well,
who do we get to see it in action?
When you saw the Barboza fight,
he's walking towards him like a Zombie
gets a hold of them. And just rag dolls.
I'm just rag dolls.
But this is what's great about this
fight and this what makes our sport so
specialist. Yeah, super bombed.
I've been in deep depression
because Ferguson fell out,
and we've talked about this off here,
but our sports so special because
what Max Holloway has the chance to do
Saturday night, if he can beat him,
if he can somehow pull that out.
There's nothing like in professional
sports, there's nothing like it.
If Lebron goes out, the team still goes
on. It's whatever. If Tom Brady gets hurt,
it sucked. But they still
play here. You know, man,
Max has a huge chance now are the
odds stacked against him? Good God.
Are they ever,
there couldn't be a worst matchup for him,
but what's the one Achilles heel,
if there is one for,
could beam a guy who can
strike going backwards.
Max Salaries Pretty fucking good
at going backwards. Yeah, it's,
it's a fascinating fight.
If there was no controversy,
if it wasn't like six day time
period for him, that's great. I know.
It's kind of cool. Do you want,
have the fight that's been like,
that was a Nate when Nate
took on Connor and the first,
here's the difference though. Nate's the
bigger guy, right? Nate's the bigger guy,
the more seasoned guy there. So for Nate,
it's like, yeah, it was short notice,
but that's a rough
matchup for Connor Connor.
It should be an underdog in that fight.
They wouldn't find it
the same weight class.
So that makes it a little more sense.
But wait a minute. They do Nate.
Nate fights at 55, uh, before that though,
he's fine at 70. Right? Oh, no, no, no.
He only fought three times at seven,
but he saw that 70 is the point.
He fired a never fought at 70. Right.
But if con when Carter fought him at 70,
that was Saturday. Yeah. College. Never
funny. You're not 70 pounder. Right.
But I mean, Nate, when he fought 70, it
didn't go well. I mean, who did he fight?
He fought Rory Macdonald. 70.
Tough. Who else did he fight?
We don't see if I had 70,
uh, lost his fights at 70, I
think wasn't great at it. No,
he didn't lose all of them. Wasn't great
one. Yeah, it wasn't great at 70. How,
but the thing is, he's the
bigger man. He's a bigger guy.
But if they agreed to fight at one 55, he
would make the one 55 weight. 100% yes.
It's like there was all this talk about
him being so much bigger than Conor. Oh,
he's bigger for sure. Taller. He's
taller. He's amazing. He's a bigger guy.
It's around heavier when he gets heavier,
but when they fight it
55 he makes that weight.
And Connor makes that weight tough too.
They both struggled to make one 55 it's
a much easier cup for counter at 55 it's
not the hardest cut.
But when you look at the difference
between how he looks physically when he
fought Nate at one 70 and how he looks
when he's, you know, one 45 he was awful.
I was going to say he's on, Donna can
make one 45 naked Nav. I mean there's,
there's no problem.
He could have made it intimate
fighter when it was cut a leg off.
You don't have to like real list.
He's not making 40 he was very thin
during the ultimate fighter days.
Remember we have to be, cause
you're on marine and fighter, right?
So you have to make weight
basically three times in a row.
Well I just think he filled in too.
I mean he was really young back then.
100% but you have to
maintain a lower weight.
That's the closest fight to it
though. I agree with that fight. No,
I agree with you. The same kind of
balls that Nate has is like what?
What it but max that differences
that like Max has taken on a guy that
everybody's avoiding. No one's
been able to, the riddle of Khabib.
No one's even ever even put
them in jeopardy like he's,
he's like a Johnson hit them,
but black rarely wasn't in a while.
It was going a bit,
we were talking about that the other day.
Who knows what was going on in that fight
because that was a fight where he had
the same issue cutting weight that
he did when he had to pull out of the
Ferguson fight where body
shutdown. Correct. So who knows?
He had that same issue with the Michael j.
He might've been severely
compromised in that fight,
even though he beat the
fuck out of a great,
the difference between Mcgregor and Diaz
is the both keeping on the feet really,
right? Yeah. He has a phenomenal
boxer comes phenomenal striker,
Max Holloway phenomena. Striker could
be phenomenal grappler. So it's a,
it's even more of a task because could be,
he's not going to sit there
and strike with him. That's
your one way to win. Cool.
I'm the best grappler on earth. Yeah.
He'll entertain it for a little bit,
but if you, if you want you down, there's
literally no one in the world from,
I'll say one 55 to one seven he's not
going to take that. I want to see,
I really want to see him in some
straight grappling competition to,
you're hearing this, hearing that about
how amazing is in the training room.
I'll tell you it from a guy like DC.
I know and and, and Fitch and hops.
You're talking about in the hall,
pioneers of the sport animals.
I want to see him against Woodley at 70
I think 70 is his natural weight class.
Yeah. I think he'd probably be
a lot healthier. Imagine that.
Imagine being stronger and healthcare.
It Woodley and Khabib. Jesus. What?
But Woodley's a different
thing, man. You, you miss you,
you fuck up and you leave yourself in
a position to get hit with one of those
nuclear bombs.
Oh,
knock out Woodley could put
people to sleep and he can
grab his ass, his ass off.
Hard to take down and puts
people to sleep with one shot.
I don't think he gets his due.
And I think the best evidence is the two
fights that people point to where they
say that like Woodley should've done
better. Those are the Thompson fights,
the end of the my fight. But
Maya, it never got hurt like he,
he hit my a bunch of times,
but it was uneventful cause he was hurt.
Woodley was her early in the
first round with the shoulder.
He fucked his shoulder up,
by the way. Should fight my,
if you don't want to go to the ground
100% but my point is in those two fights
with Thompson Woodley was
the one who hurt Thompson.
He hurt him that bad in both fights.
Almost stopped him in both fights. Yeah.
I don't see them ever fight again,
but I hear you. Great Fun. Yeah.
I'll pass hard pass where there was
a crazy UFC 200 cards that was on it.
I wouldn't be mad. He was one of
the, as a main event, I get it.
I get it. I like twice.
Wow. Cool. Yeah. No,
that's a super complicated upset, upset
though. They're just not good day.
It's one and the same thing.
If they just said no,
this time it's gonna be different.
I'm going to war,
go to war and then two rounds and you
like bastard is circling each other.
That's like Dana on a Ferguson and Khabib.
He's like,
that fights never happened to a fifth
time not happening. I'm like, I get it.
I get it man. It's such a bummer
though. Let's talk business like,
I don't know how many paper
views this was going to do,
but for the hardcore fans,
this was a big one.
This was a big one because this is
the first time could be biz fighting.
A guy that's super versatile,
they can fight standing up,
can knock you out with one shot.
Tough is Falk has incredible endurance
and can grab off his back and the most
dangerous guy it could be will ever face.
Yeah.
Tony Ferguson has the perfect
style to test what was,
so we could really find out where could
bebes act cause we know we're Tony's at
we and we kind of know
where it could bebes at.
Okay.